[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
did Dark Brandon show up this morning or
is this dank Brandon not really sure the
one keeps saying dark Brandon so I'm
gonna believe you I don't know
seems like
maybe maybe there's a little bit of dank
Brandon in there too I don't know have
you seen this new ad have you seen this
new ad that Joe Biden the president to
Joe Biden I put out this morning he's
announcing he's going to run in 2024. no
[__] Sherlock guess what
guess what he's gonna be the nominee hey
hey Jank over at tyt he's gonna be the
nominee you [__] whiny little [__]
everyone's everyone's there's well not
everyone most of my audience understands
exactly why I feel the way I feel about
tyt and Jank over there
why I feel that way because they feel
the same [__] way okay but the reason
why I'm going after him is because that
piece of [__] is lying to his audience
okay there's one thing I will not
tolerate and and you know I've gotten
this [__] before where I go after tyt
and people like Tony why do you go after
tyt they go after the left no they don't
they go after democracy you [__]
fools if listen if you're defending Jank
over at tyt
you're you're you're against democracy
that's what that's what you're doing I
don't give a sh you can you can be mad
at me and you can leave and you'll be
back trust me you'll be back you'll be
back
but Jank over there doesn't give a [__]
about the institution of democracy he
only cares about one goddamn thing and
that's his pockets being full that's it
so he lies to his audience
listen folks I've told you this once
I've tell you a million [__] times
Jank knows exactly how the Democratic
primaries work and when there is an
incumbent president
in the Democratic Party
that decides to run for a second term
that person is going to be the nominee
barring some extreme unknown
circumstance
listen to me when I tell you this there
is no use for Democrats at all or anyone
in the pro-democracy coalition to get
worried upset or get all bent out of
shape because Joe Biden's gonna be the
nominee that's how it works
you tell me
and and yeah I know a lot of people are
gonna hate in the comments because this
is in the first [__] five minutes I
get it I get it
but here's here's here's what I'll tell
you go show me go show me a reasonable
challenge to any incumbent Democratic
president that we have had in modern
history show it to me
show it to me
when you show me when and who it was
then we can talk
that's the Democratic party's process
this is the same stupid [__] that tyt
and the Bernie Bros bitched about in
2016. it's the same nonsense okay it's
the same nonsense but then there wasn't
even an incumbent if you remember
2016 at all Bernie or bust that's what
it was burning your bust
they didn't understand how the super
delegates in the Democratic party work
they just don't they don't [__] get
it and I'm not saying the super
delegates is the best system
it's better than what the Republicans
have because in 2016 if the Republicans
would have had super delegates they
would have boxed Donald Trump out of
being president altogether
yes is it establishment yes is it
politics yes does it does it not breed
new blood into the Democratic party and
the leadership Maybe
maybe it does maybe it doesn't but it
doesn't matter what it does or doesn't
do it is what it is and that is the fact
that is reality stop trying to live in
an alternative reality where you get to
pull [__] crazy stupid cult-like [__]
out of thin air
we are not Republicans we are not
fascists we are not delusional cult
members okay so stop acting like it
everyone's like oh Tony wolf you support
Biden then you're a cult member I don't
support Biden I'm against Fascism and so
is Joe Biden to to 99.9 of the degree
okay
fascism is the enemy here not [__]
Joe Biden you dumb [__]
and if you like your democracy and you
want to keep it for the future then you
need to keep your eye on who the [__]
wants to destroy it
that's what you have to do that's what
we do here every single weekday
and yesterday we had Dr Rachel bittick
offer on and she told you the exact same
thing about tyt if you're listening to
that trash then then you're being you're
having your mind [__] okay you're
having your mind [__] and they're
trying to reprogram you yes every single
program everything they say is not
exactly that but the overall arcing
message and narrative over there is that
both sides are exactly the same
and it's just not [__] true it's not
true at all and somehow both sides are
just as much of a threat to democracy as
one or the other [__] you [__] you Jank
[__] you Anna [__] you tyt that's what I
say and maybe I'll get in trouble for it
but you think I give a [__] no because
I'm gonna tell you the real raw truth
about it whether you like it or you
don't
so you can you can come at me with the
tyts on our side but they're not on the
side of democracy they're on the side of
profits dummy
so get it through your thick [__]
skull when you're over there watching
tyt fine
but understand what they're doing
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
anyone I I guaran damned to you I guaran
damn [__] to you you're not gonna get
anyone on the left who says [__] the way
I say it why I say it and how I say it
not a [__] not one show them to
me
you present them to me and maybe I'll
believe you
you're not gonna see it
and yeah are they passionate over at tyt
are they Liberals are they socialists
are they Democratic socialists Maybe
but that doesn't make them Defenders of
the pro-democracy Coalition and
democracy itself they're [__]
self-defeatist at best they're already
self-defeating
already before Joe Biden even announces
of course he announced before he
announced and when he was going to
announce but everyone knew even me
that he's gonna be the nominee it
doesn't [__] matter what you want
what you want to cry about how you wanna
frame it
Joe Biden is the incumbent president of
the United States
he has the full-fledged right to run in
the race as the as a as a as a nominee
and he will win that race and of course
people are like oh there's no there's no
Democratic debates who's he gonna debate
who's he gonna debate there ain't a
[__] gonna win delegates
who the [__] is he gonna debate for
delegates you understand that's how it
works right
once people pluck their head out of
their ass like Jank which he knows how
it [__] works he's lying to his
audience he's bullshitting them he's
feeding them [__] is what he's doing
to keep them listening
whatever will keep them outraged about
whatever the [__] it is regardless if
it's a threat to our democracy or not
he'll lie to them as if Joe Biden's a
threat to our democracy get the [__] out
of here with that nonsense you may not
agree with everything he does you may
not agree with every policy that the
Biden Administration has [__] you may
you may not agree with their with their
their political strategy which I do not
for sure
why do you think I don't [__] talk
about talk about the White House a lot
because if I had to I'd be on here
[__] yelling screaming at him but
they're not the threat to democracy
folks
so get it through your head get it
through your head Joe Biden will be the
na money Jank
sort what are you gonna do are you going
to encourage people not to vote for the
pro-democracy candidate and to make sure
to secure democracy in this country
because there's only one party
interested in democracy at all I don't
know if you [__] notice this but the
other party's trying to strip away
rights from women lgbtq people that
parents consent
I don't know if you [__] notice that
libraries public schools on and on and
on it goes you're right to [__]
practice the religion that you want or
don't want
I don't know if you noticed that [__]
maybe maybe maybe when you take a little
bit of time and a break from being so
mad that Joe Biden isn't the Socialist
that you want him to be maybe you'll
think about what the [__] is the threat
to democracy
but he can't because he's he's really
the thing he's paying attention to the
most is his [__] bank account
because you better bet I'm telling you
you better bet
the way I say [__] and how I say [__]
does not equal money
no one wants to give me [__] money
the way I talk
it's the audience that supports me
that's it
and you come here for me to give you
real raw truth regardless of what the of
what the motivation is
because the motivation is just to give
it to you straight rather you [__]
like it or not I I mean what am I gonna
do
what possibly could I do to spend
something
other than to just give it to you
straight like yesterday with the uh
Tucker Carlson Don Lemon thing someone
was messaging me on Twitter before I
came on air uh there's someone in the uh
in the uh an audience member
and they were worried about my stance on
Don Lemon well I went over this
yesterday and really I even said that I
wasn't gonna hash out Don Lemon too much
but the one reason why I think Don Lemon
is gone is because CNN is moving to the
right they're trying to attract fox in
the right-wing audience CNN scenes the
writing on the wall here about oan and
Newsmax they're [__] done folks if
they get sued the way Fox News got sued
they're [__] I mean capital f u c k
[__] [__] [__] there ain't no way
they're gonna survive that hell Fox News
would be lucky to survive a settlement
with smartmatic that's why Tucker
Carlson's gone you can say whatever you
want about Fox News and Tucker Carlson
that they they needed heads to roll and
and Rupert Murdoch was pissed off
because Tucker Carlson has creative
control over that 8 P.M hour and Rupert
wants the creative control of that 8 PM
hour back because let's face it I said
this yesterday too Tucker Carlson isn't
popular and famous with the right wing
because he's really good at what he does
Tucker Carlson is in the 8 P.M hour
where they have the highest ratings he
took over Bill O'Reilly's spot Jesus
Christ they could put a [__] they
could put a Nazi ham sandwich
to do that hour the 8 PM hour and it'll
get just as many [__] viewers
that's it it'll be the number one
[__] hour on cable news
because there's a ton of [__] help
there's a ton
of trumped-up Boomers watching that
[__] 8 P.M hour
whether you like it or not that's just
what is happening
and that's why all the eyeballs are on
that hour that's why Tucker Carlson was
so goddamn popular because he was
sitting in front of millions of them all
at once
it's that complicated this [__] isn't
complicated people want to make it
[__] all kinds of intricate and oh
man well what if it had to do with his
his misogyny really you think you think
Rupert Murdoch just woke up yesterday
morning he's like you know what I think
I think touch Tucker's a misogynist so
I'm gonna fire him today the [__] out of
here with that nonsense
the reason why Fox News has such a
problem with sexual harassment and
misogyny over there is because of Rupert
Murdoch and the culture that he created
what makes you think he's going to try
to [__] undo that culture get the
[__] out of here the guy's in his 90s
are his thousands I don't know he's like
4 000 years old or some [__]
the reason why Tucker Carlson is gone is
because the board and the [__]
shareholders said hey his head's gotta
roll
and Rupert Murdoch wants the creative
control of that 8 PM hour back
he does not want to have to spend
another 800 million dollars in the next
election in a defamation lawsuit because
someone like Tucker Carlson gets to say
whatever the [__] he wants on his air
what the f what the [__] don't you
people get about that
it's not complicated back to Don Lemon
I and someone some people say lemon
different am I wrong I don't know I
don't watch [__] CNN
I'd watch clips of lemon phew not a lot
because let's face it Don isn't that
good he's really not he's not that good
folks he's a hack he's a [__] hack
that's why he's on CNN MSNBC CNN Fox
News they're all [__] hacks
none of them [__] tell the truth
they're all [__] constrained by some
kind of control in their contract as
well as Don Lemon
and Don Lemon seems to want to litigate
his contract that CNN broke it which may
be the case that may be the case that
CNN broke his contract and in that
manner
Don lemon's gonna have a huge payday so
great for Don Lemon I don't know who the
[__] cares he'll end up on news Nation
like with his buddy Chris Cuomo anyways
apparently I was right yesterday when uh
news Nation they've had Bill Ryan they
have Bill O'Reilly and Chris Cuomo's
program they got all kinds of [__]
Old Washington packs over there at news
nation and they try to play as like
there's some kind of non-biased [__]
uh news organization but they're biased
as [__] the right wing is [__] just go
watch the [__]
just watch 10 minutes of the [__] and
you'll know exactly who they are and
what they're trying to do they're trying
to sell you a right-wing message under
the guise of oh no it's neutral it's
neutral because I don't hide what the
[__] I do here do I have I ever hid what
I do here
I think this is called liberal media
this isn't mainstream if you think this
is mainstream then you got your head
[__] on backwards
but CNN MSNBC Fox News ABC NBC CBS
they're all supposed to be mainstream
and that's the world that they don't
live in that they should live in
they should be journalists is what they
should be doing
not sensationalist leave the sensation
to the performers the entertainers the
clowns like me
that's what you should leave the
sensation to
but they need ratings they need money
right
the same way Jake needs money
that's why yesterday he went on a
full-fledged attack of Joe Biden in his
nomination that he knows Joe Biden's
gonna get
the bitching and the whining and the
crying dude direct your energy Jake
here's here's my advice really honestly
if you if you want if you because
yesterday he was like I believe in
democracy and of course I'm gonna vote
for Joe Biden if he's the choice between
him and Trump
Jake here's my advice to you buddy and
and here's here's all here's my advice
to all the fans out there that love tyt
and Jank
here's my advice
Focus your energy on something that will
[__] help with your voice and your
platform dummy
do that
if you care about democracy if you care
so much about democracy then at least
pretend like it for a half a second
you [__] half wit
so you know
love me or hate me because of how I put
pressure on the left because that's what
they always say when I start talking
[__] about tyt Tony
don't you know that that tyt holds the
left accountable look they are the left
what are you talking about what the f
who the [__] are they some non-biased
[__] investigative news reporters get
the [__] out of here
get the [__] out of here if you think
that tyt and all the creators over there
on tyt and the personalities on tyt are
some sort of neutral [__]
investigative body investigating both
sides and they call out both sides get
the [__] out of here they are the left
hell they're more left than I am for
crying out loud and I end up when when I
get raided I end up being more extreme
left than they are than half their
[__] shows probably because I yell
and scream more than they do I don't
know I don't know how these [__] they
they decide I'm extreme left
I don't know I mean I I'm not opposed to
it go ahead whatever you want to call me
I don't give a [__] I'm gonna keep
talking whether you like me or not I'm
gonna keep talking whether you like what
I'm saying or not I'm gonna keep talking
and yelling and screaming about our
democracy rather whether you believe it
or not or it takes you a while to
[__] come around to Common Sense
that liberalism is the strength of
democracy
liberalism that that word Liber roll
that is the strength of democracy
that is the beacon
of equity and equality whether you like
it or not that's the direction
and here on the Tony Michaels podcast
we're going to have the new liberalism I
don't give a [__] however you want to
frame it up however you want to go tell
your friends
rather you want to call I've called it
pro-democracy propaganda oh that really
[__] gets in people's crawl when you
say the word propaganda oh they get a
whole [__] Jesus Christ Jesus Christ
that's a bad word well there's a lot of
[__] bad words
and you are have the complete utter
right and Liberty to be offended I don't
care
you had the right to be offended by what
I say you have the right to not like
what I say you have the right to not
believe or or agree with what I say but
I'm telling you one goddamn thing I'm
telling you for sure right now
you'll be back
and you'll watch this show and the
reason why is because there's no one
else on the left doing it the way that I
do it not Jank not tyt there isn't
anyone
go [__] find him and show them to me
this show is specifically designed a
certain way
that's the whole point that's why they
call me the Limbaugh the left
because the format Works folks it
[__] works
trust me I I see the analytics of our
small little audience as they want to
call it
did you know
um we have 15 000 subscribers on YouTube
uh well we're almost to 16 I think
like it's 16 000 subscribers
most the time we have upwards of 10 of
that number watching live across
platforms ten percent of our YouTube
audience watches live
okay
now that that doesn't seem significant
but you just do the math in your head
and that's a huge number
that's huge
we had we had we have almost six million
minutes watched in the last 28 days
and that means people are watching from
the very beginning of the show the very
end of the show
that's that's important
and the reason why it's important for
our democracy
I'm trying to show you the threats I'm
trying to show you what they're trying
to do their strategy to undo your
[__] Liberty
so Jank and tyt can complain all the
[__] they want for the next 18 months
about how oh Joe Biden Joe Biden he
didn't have to debate nobody oh he
didn't get to run Marianne Williamson
they're not giving her any air time
guess what I'm gonna give Marianne
Williamson some [__] air time today
and tyt and Marianne Williams ain't
gonna [__] like it
that she's not gonna like it
she's not gonna like when I have to say
what I have to say about her and about
tyt and them propping her up acting like
she's
acting like she's gonna have any [__]
delegates in Chicago next next summer
get the [__] out of here you think
Marianne Williamson is gonna walk into
the Democratic National Convention with
enough delegates to beat an incumbent
president in the Democratic primary
you are a dumb [__] if you think
that is a possibility you just you just
are uncoupled and untethered from
reality
so stop stop being stop being members of
The Cult
because I'm telling you this is not a
cult here this is called Freedom this is
called Liberty you get to believe what
you want to believe here
on this side of the aisle you get to be
who the [__] you want to be
and we may not like it
but we'll [__] defend it
I'll [__] defend your right to be a
dumb [__]
to the end of time because it's your
[__] Liberty and your [__] right
if you want to be some trumped up idiot
fine go ahead beat my guest I mean
you're not you're not gonna not get
mocked here on the Tony Michaels podcast
but you damn sure are gonna have the
Liberty to believe your stupid ideas as
long as you don't act on them listen
your hatred and your bigotry you get to
hold it as a belief but you start acting
under the Tate crimes we do have laws in
this country
and that's why liberalism Reigns true in
the strength of our democracy is because
we have laws
but you get to [__] believe all the
crazy [__] you want
I I welcome people who don't agree with
me here on the show
[__] I I would have Jank on the show
someone said yesterday that I should uh
debate him it wouldn't really be much of
a debate but I'd have Jake on the show
if he wanted to be on the show
I don't give a [__] he wouldn't like it
he wouldn't last very long he'd probably
hang up on me
because I wouldn't be very [__] nice
to him I just wouldn't because I think
what he's doing is scummy and vile and
it's a grift and he's lying to his
audience because he knows better
he's not [__] dumb I mean yes I call
him a dumb [__]
but the reason why he's being dumb is
because he's playing this dumb argument
to his stupid [__] audience
because let's face it folks let's face
it and this is this is a conversation
I'm not gonna have too many times so you
better listen up because I'm not gonna
talk about the left that much on my show
but this is a conversation we we're
gonna have to have and today is the
perfect day to have it when people are
out there like I don't want you biting
to be present he's too old let's get
Bernie Sanders what are you listening to
yourself do you are you looking in the
mirror before you make these arguments
thank you
folks
we have to save our democracy I told you
in 2022 that that was the most important
election of our democracy's lifetime and
it was and it's over it's now 2024.
2024 is the one we focus on and in 2022
and some special election sense we have
we have we have made sure that the
safety net of democracy is there in 2022
we made sure in Pennsylvania Michigan
Wisconsin and Arizona that the governors
the attorney generals and the Secretary
of States were not [__] treasonous
pieces of [__] that were willing to
overturn elections for an authoritarian
like Trump or any other [__] manga
real America First Nazi
we put that Safety Net in place in
Wisconsin
in Wisconsin in a special election for
the Supreme Court we made sure
that we didn't have some [__] crazy
ass fascist extremists on the court to
make sure to protect those elections
when we vote for these people and we
place them in power they're there
it is our vote that puts them there we
are the government get it through your
thick skull
and you can say what you want about Joe
Biden's age or what he is or what he
isn't but he's but you cannot say he's
not going to be the nominee [__]
is going to be the nominee
and Donald Trump is going to be the
Republican nominee get it through your
thick head
know the facts know what's gonna happen
I'm telling you what's gonna happen I've
been saying it for months I've been
telling you for months that Ron DeSantis
was not going to get in this race
yesterday he [__] fell flat on his
face
you think you I
yesterday
this video of him going I'm not running
that is gonna hurt him more than his
stupid fascist policy that he is putting
in place in Florida I hate to say it but
that's the truth
that's gonna hurt that image of him
doing that bobble-headed [__] is gonna
hurt him more in the Republican primary
than his fascist [__] ideas it's sad
to say but it's true
it's just the way it's going to be Ron
DeSantis is done
and if he does run he'll be he'll be
finished fast as soon as these primaries
start
because I don't think o Ronnie knows
what's coming for him
I don't think he knows his career is
done
so
strap in folks 2024 has started dark
Brandon strikes
and he has announced to be president the
nominee for the Democratic presidential
candidate
of the United States of America and he
sure as hell will be
bet on it don't go anywhere we'll be
right back with Texas Paul we'll get his
opinion maybe he'll maybe he'll
challenge me I don't know probably not
I think Texas ball normally agrees with
exactly what I'm saying sometimes we
disagree but we'll see Texas Paul Gabe
Sanchez when we come back right after
this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [__]
um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
you guys see the uh the ad that the
president of the United States put out
what an ad I tell you that that's a hell
of a start
um to a to a second term campaign hell
um he didn't have to brag much about
what he's done uh and and he's basically
saying hey let's let's make sure we keep
defending democracy here we've been
doing it for four years that's why you
elected me to defend democracy
uh from these authoritarians that are
trying to strip away your rights trying
to strip away your Liberty and we're
going to keep doing it Texas Paul is
joining us now Texas Paul did you see
the ad that the president United States
put out this morning did you see it
I hate to disappoint you but I have not
seen a great no no that's good because
I'm going to show it to the audience
here so I I'm I'm kind of glad that you
haven't launched it because now now the
audience will get your real reaction in
real time so I'm I'm not gonna say I'm
sad that you haven't seen it so I'm kind
of excited about it
I've actually been working on uh
something nasty Donovan firing actually
is a little bit bigger than most people
thought you know I I didn't think much
of it to begin with it didn't really
care I don't not a big Don Lemon Don
Lemon fan and and uh but the interview
that ended up getting him fired uh is
actually tied to a pretty big [__]
deal but I'm I'm working on that
it's a big story it's going to take a
while to put together so sorry I was
actually talking about this Vivek guy
yeah
no I I've been I've been in Twitter
spaces as a speaker with this Vivek guy
um and you know I I'll be honest and
I've asked him on Twitter like I've
tagged him and asked him
um if Trump is is funding his campaign
to run against Trump
um because it feels like that to me some
to some degree and because he doesn't
know [__] like he doesn't know [__]
about politics and I'm not saying that's
a bad thing but I'm saying it's a
horrible thing for someone who wants to
run for the highest office in the land
who doesn't know [__] modern
political history and doesn't know
history in general but but is so
ignorant of how politics works that's
not someone you want to be the highest
ranking politician in the land and
really in the Free World is my opinion
of Avec he's a he's a hack and he's paid
by someone he's funding by someone to
run around and pretend that's what I'm
digging into right now yeah well I I
think I think that's I think that's a
worthy thing to invest investigate but
you're saying you're saying that that
because I because I I watched that clip
of Don Lemon and Vivek like kind of
going back and forth do you think that's
the reason why he got fired is that what
you're saying well you know I I don't
want to give too much away at this point
but I will tell you this do you remember
a guy by the name of Grover norquist he
he was the head of the American tax
reform used to be oh we had to sign his
pledge his tax pledge or you weren't a
republican exactly that guy he's also on
the board of the NRA he is an American
he's a right-wing activist and he he was
really famous for a statement that they
didn't need a president to think they
just needed a president with enough
working digits to sign the bills that
they put in front of him
right I am working on who the [__] they
is
oh really
they want just a just a wet ink pen is
that what you're saying yeah no that I
have to tell you it really Vivek
ramaswami was actually not uh
we didn't think much of him because we
didn't know much of him but he has Heavy
Hitters behind him he really does Trump
was supposed to be their guy that fit
that description he was supposed to just
go into the White House live his best
life be the the
[__] that he is right you know and and
it's just a [__] isn't he that's really
that's a really good term for him is
[__]
yeah he is he really is he was just
supposed to go shut the [__] up and and
and do what he was told
and he couldn't do it he's a
megalomaniac he he really thinks he's
smarter than everybody in the room
and he screwed their hole
operation right he screwed their whole
operation uh because he started thinking
for himself and doing really stupid [__]
which ended up making him one of the few
incumbent presidents to never be
re-elected
I mean it's just that's a pretty rare
Club I mean for Jimmy for it to happen
to Jimmy Carter we had to have a world
altering event with the Saudis and their
Oil Embargo right you know I mean it it
takes a lot for an incumbent not to and
that goes right into what you were
talking about with Joe Biden it takes a
lot for an incumbent president to not be
re-elected right it takes a guy look at
the nomination even this idea that
somehow he's going to be challenged and
people like Jake Unger and on tyt are
bitching that there's not going to be
debates get the [__] at debates on what
what delegates what delegates is
Marianne Williamson going to bring to
the stage to debate Joe Biden on there's
not a debate why why would Joe Biden the
incumbent president who is going to wrap
up 99 and if not 100 of the delegates to
debate Marianne Williamson who may bring
one delegate to the to the convention in
Chicago if she can even get on enough
balance to bring one delegate it's
almost like we went through this [__] in
2016 where the left you know hashed out
the super delegates it was changed a bit
for 2020. Bernie Sanders didn't have a
[__] shot in 2016 because the super
delegates didn't have a shot in hell in
2020 when Joe Biden after South Carolina
when it was clear what what the
Democratic party won it wasn't Medicare
for all that's not what the Democratic
party wanted that's the message that
Bernie Sanders was selling and the
Democratic party said no we want to
[__] beat Trump [__] your [__] your
[__] your your Universal Health Care
Medicare for all [__] we want to save
democracy we want to beat Trump is what
we want and so they chose Joe Biden the
person who would beat Trump I mean I
guess you could argue that Bernie
Sanders could beat Joe Biden but but
listen Bernie Sanders and I've been
following Bernie Sanders for a long time
a long time Bernie Sanders is not a
Democrat Texas ball he's not he the only
time he's ever changed his party is when
he wants to run when he wants to run but
also when he gets on the floor of the
Democratic National Convention and he
wants to hand over the Democratic
delegates for Vermont that's the only
time that he switches and he switches
right back to independent and I'm not
saying that's wrong I actually believe
that that Bernie Sanders being the
independent United States senator from
Vermont is good for the left it's good
for our narrative because Bernie Sanders
gets to pull it to the left he gets to
say whatever the [__] he wants without
and he can get reelected he can say the
craziest [__] he wants to say as a
United States Senator Joe Biden doesn't
get to say the craziest [__] he wants he
doesn't get to do that he doesn't get to
because he's the Democratic president
he's expecting he doesn't want to either
let's face it he's very right of Sinner
I mean he's not a left-wing liberal
right right he's not you know I mean
I mean he's pulled left throughout the
years but I mean he he is he is uh if
there is truly a politician that can be
considered moderate in this country uh
throughout their entire career probably
we would be Joe Biden
okay maybe I don't think so right to me
to me I mean I I'm not arguing with you
I'm just saying that to me I look at him
he's writer Center he is he is who we
need right now we need a guy that is not
a Bernie Sanders that doesn't have this
let's radically change the country Big
Ideas because that's not where people
are
you you know after Trump people were
pretty traumatized they needed sane they
needed just keeps keep the [__]
lights on is what they needed
you know they and I'm sorry for cussing
so much Tony I know that
the way that things are changing on the
internet that's getting to be a bad man
oh it hurts my feelings
but you know he uh
he's the guy we needed you know and I'll
admit I didn't support the guy I was I
was a mayor Pete guy I wanted young
blood in the party this that and the
other and that's why I founded the rider
died Democrats that's why I did that
that you know that's where I come from
right or die Democrats you want to
support Marianne Williamson go ahead but
we're we're Jake gets it wrong is nobody
did you put tape on her mouth I didn't
put tape on her mouth she can run she
can say whatever the hell she wants to
say what what [__] is crying like a
little [__] about is that he wants us
to elevate her
to the same level
as Joe Biden and she's not no well she's
not I got a clip to show you she's not
here's a clip of her yes the other day
talking in a church uh with American
flags it's starting to feel like Maga
here but listen listen to the word sad I
don't know what she's saying really
honestly but let's listen to this also
uh recognize as I have as as Doug said
that interface that intersection between
those things which are religious and
those things which are political Mahatma
Gandhi said that anyone who thinks
religion doesn't have anything to do
with politics doesn't understand
religion so the separation of church and
state means our government will not be
interfered with by religious authorities
and those of us who worship or not
worship will not be interfered with in
that decision by governmental
authorities
important that we understand that and
it's also important to understand what
the Johnson amendment was that has to do
with what churches can or cannot do on
the pulpit
if okay so wait for this Texas ball
because it feels like it feels like to
me she's saying oh this separation of
church and state is good right it feels
like that's what she's saying but listen
to what she says here at the end feels a
little Christian nationalist if you want
if you want to know the honest truth
here listen to this yeah
we're to say specific Ally we endorse
this candidate he would be risking the
tax-exempt status if he were to say
specifically we endorse this piece of
legislation that would be risking his uh
his um uh tax-exempt status but that's
it it does not mean you can't let it rip
about what you believe it does not mean
you can't let it rip about what your
heart has to say it does not mean you
can't let it rip about your spiritual
convictions on the pulpit and that's
what I intend to do today
okay Texas fall I don't I don't know if
Marianne Williamson realizes this
um but but most people in this country
right now who who are probably going to
go vote for Joe Biden in the primary
aren't going to bind the religious
[__] I don't know if she's got the
memo or not but um this [__] weird
thing where she's on the stage going oh
the reason why there's separation
between church and state is because tax
exempt status you are so full of [__]
that is not why tax exempt status that
might be some [__] uh thing tool that
we use to make sure that church and
state state stay separate in this
country we don't even enforce it right
but that was never the original
intention is to is to have churches not
be taxed and if they don't get involved
in politics then they they they won't
have to pay taxes people are dumb that's
the dumbest [__] argument I've heard
in my life about Pro and from a person
who thinks they're going to be Joe Biden
in a Democratic primary this is the
stupidest [__] I've ever heard of listen
Marianne Williamson she may be great on
tyt she may do great I don't know I've
never watched her on dyd because I don't
watch that [__] trash but here's the
thing is that she may be great on their
TV station or whatever they the hell
they're doing over there but when when
it gets down to real brass tax politics
retail politics out there she is going
to flop around and Flounder like a
goddamn dead fish I'm telling you it's
not going to go over well it's not going
to work out well for her in the
Democratic primary it's just that no
yeah and you you know what Tony you can
watch her she doesn't have it
you know and people don't like this but
it's the truth I'll never lie to you it
doesn't matter you can be the best
person in the world the smartest person
in the world and you can run for office
and fall flat on your face if you don't
have it there is a presence that you
must have for people to follow you
other than that you're just a tool
you're just a tool for the machine
that's it and she doesn't have it the
Democratic party that's why we need
super delegates on our side we're not a
party of oligarchs their super delegates
are the oligarchs they vote with their
checks
that that's what they vote with our
super delegates we need to keep our
Armada flowing in the same direction
the Democratic party does not interfere
with primaries and and caucuses they do
not if you've got it
they want you
up there they win voters they want to
win yeah yeah but if you are like Bernie
which was you know I I Bernie in 2028
would be amazing it would but we don't
need
a far left candidate right now because
that's not where the American people are
did you just just wait I just want to
make sure I understood you right did you
just say Bernie Sanders in 2028 how old
do you think this guy's gonna oh no not
him specifically
I was like God damn man if everyone's
knocking on Joe Biden for being old in
2024 what the hell are we gonna talk
about in 2028 if Bernie Sanders is
running
and by the way I just want I just want
to tell everybody out there that I'm not
against Bernie I'm not an anti-burnie I
mean I I'm I'm I [__] hate the stupid
Bernie or bust idea but this the thing
that I'll tell you is is that Bernie is
100 behind Joe Biden he will be so if
you like Bernie and you follow Bernie
and you think you love Bernie just know
that Bernie's gonna be 100 behind Joe
Biden just know that and let me tell you
if Bernie was ahead
you know it had been ahead
when when Hillary was running against
Hillary Clinton
this would have been a very different
this debate it would have been he would
have been backed by the party he was not
he was behind Hillary Clinton
you know we just have to be open about
that he was not beating Hillary Clinton
and he had very very radical different
ideas from what the mainstream was
so the party did the calculus they
looked at the situation and said okay
super delegates you go Hillary because
we need to maintain this stability right
here right now
Bernie does not have the popular support
to move an entire country if we stay
mainstream middle of the road right of
Center where everybody's at right now
then yeah
you know and people don't like to hear
it but it's the truth the party has to
maintain some sense of control because
like you say they want to win
Bernie would have been just ruffle
stomped into a mud hole by Trump think
about that campaign
you know Hillary Clinton was a heavy
hitter with huge backers
to me she wasn't harsh enough if she'd
have been more aggressive I think she
could have won that but
I mean Bernie they would have destroyed
they would have destroyed they would
have whittled him down to his core base
of followers which would have been 20 or
30 percent and Trump would have won that
election by at least
15 points right well I mean here's
here's the other thing too that a lot of
people aren't calculating and this is
this is the thing in the Forefront of my
mind and I want the audience to know
this and I want the audience to use this
as a selling point of why democracy uh
if we engage in it will be safe
um if if we have a trump Biden rematch
which is 100 likely maybe 99.9 Texas
Ball but it is very likely that we're
gonna have a trump Biden rematch here
the thing that the Democrats know in
that rematch is exactly exactly in every
single Precinct how many and where the
boat the votes for Biden is and that is
the most important part about this if
you throw Ron DeSantis and Marianne
Williamson on ticket we ain't got a
[__] clue we have no idea where those
votes are no clue we know where the
Trump Biden votes will be we know it we
know it we've seen in the last and even
as the demographics change it's going to
change in our favor anyways we know that
from the Kansas referendum we know that
from the Wisconsin Supreme Court vote we
know that from the 2022 midterm we know
that that the Republicans are totally
going to underestimate the turnout that
we can have and the reason why they're
so focused on suppressing the vote is
because they're terrified of our turnout
machine and Gen X or excuse me gen Z
they're terrified that gen Z is going to
turn out and they're going to pound them
and bury them in mountains of votes
because they're sick of their fascist
[__] so this this idea that somehow Joe
Biden is a is a is a Surefire loser you
are you just do not know exactly how
elections work if that's your stance no
there's a reason that incumbents get
re-elected at about 90 percent
I mean there's a reason and they like to
argue that modern presidential history
that doesn't pan out because you got
what let me see I got a list here uh
H.W Carter and Ford in modern history
that did not get reelected you've got
Reagan Bush and Obama that did well you
look at the political landscape around
each of those I mean you had the Nixon
resignation they didn't choose Ford he
was not he was elected to be a
congressman and then appointed to be
speaker and then appointed to be vice
president which he just fell into the
presidency I'm going to say something
really unpopular here but it would be
akin to if Joe Biden had to step down
and Kamala Harris took his spot right
you know we like Kamala Harris we do but
is she going to win a presidential
election [__] no never never not gonna
happen you nominate Kamala Harris and
we're done wow
we know that from the from the 2020
primary
she just she didn't even she didn't even
rise to the star that she should have
been in that primary
um and I don't know exactly what it is
the difference between her being an
attorney general of California United
States Senator but like you said earlier
there is just something about being a
Presidential nominee that you gotta have
and if you ain't got it you ain't got it
and I'm saying that I love the harrises
I really do they are absolutely
she's a hell of a fighter for justice
she's a hell of a fighter for democracy
I and I know there's there's blemishes
on a record but they're politicians
folks they're not always going to be
correct they're not always going to get
policy right but they have to be serious
about it and she's a serious person
other than the people you see running on
the right they're not [__] serious at
all I mean Jesus Christ let me show you
this clip Texas ball this is uh Grandpa
Poopypants Still Still litigating Ashley
Babbitt and what should happen to the
cop who was defending our democracy that
day
yeah but watch watch this [__] this is
[__] crazy they're weaponizing law
enforcement at a level that nobody's
ever seen before and it's very dangerous
to the country and our country is not
going to stand for it you know we have
very strong people in this country and
they've been sitting back and watching
they've been watching they've watched
that the whole situation with the
capitol they didn't walk in with guns
they shot Ashley Babbitt that officer
bad things should happen to him he's
what was that I I don't mean really The
Wine Room gave sinjas he says bad things
should happen to that officer that was
defending the capital that day now you
know you may agree or disagree with that
officer's use of the type of force that
he used in that moment but they were
told time and time again to back away
from the [__] door they were told to
back away from the window and they were
busting down violently a window in a
state capital in a protected area of the
capital
and they may have not have known that
but that does not mean that they do not
have to defend that area of the capital
that officer charged charged with the
duty to defend that part of the capital
yeah the cops knew the cops knew they
were armed that that [__] fat ass
orange liar can sit there and say
everything he wants but the cops knew
you know we we had the radio traffic on
on when we did the January 6 coverage we
know that they were [__] arms and we
knew that the cops were told don't
escalate this don't start exchanging
gunfire don't do it
you know and and Michael bird had the
utmost restraint until she came through
that window where there was no place for
the people he was protecting to go if
that crowd came through that because if
she came through the window everybody
else came through that [__] window
right that door opened up if Ashley
Babbitt had got her hand to that
doorknob
Trump would be president
I'm not kidding you Trump would be
president right now
and we would have had a bloodbath we
would have had people [__] attacked
this would have been
turned into a complete authoritarian
State because that is what they wanted
they wanted a member of Congress
physically attacked so that President
Trump at the time he was President could
declare an emergency
run the clock out have the state's vote
put him back in office and we are we
were a fascist state
Michael bird is a goddamn hero that
saved our democracy
and he did he put his life on the line
they told him you opened fire these
people are [__] armed you're gonna
end up in a gunfight you cannot win
and he did it anyways he did his job he
put his life on the line when he did
that well and when you watch the video
of Ashley Babbitt being shot moments
after she shot laying on the ground is
when the actual the other law
enforcement with long guns show up up
the stairs so they were waiting for
those Law Enforcement Officers to get up
the stairs before they would use Force
but he forced she forced him to use
force uh tiffy's here says Ashley bad a
Babbitt unaligned herself really what
what did it to Ashley Babbitt was q and
i q Anon killed Ashley babbitted deluded
her into this state and she believed the
lies and Donald Trump led her to the
Capitol to her death to her death
because he lied to her he [__] lied
to her and he's the and now he's sitting
there on TV lying that she was murdered
and and winking winking and his
supporters to say hey go do something to
the cop you know what's funny I think
though Texas Paul is anytime he does
this inciting a violence right out in
the open especially when he's doing in
interview that there's not a [__]
peep it's crickets his this idea that he
has a [__] huge base that's gonna
follow him into the pits of hell as a
[__] lie it's a goddamn fraud the
people who are going to commit violence
for him and break laws for him they did
it on January 6th they [__] around and
found out and there's not too many of
them left that's going to be willing to
do it they're just not it's all [__]
it's all for clout online it's just a
bunch of nonsense well he doesn't have
the AstroTurf behind him anymore either
because these oligarchs have figured out
he's uncontrollable they don't want him
he's super negative he turns our base
out he is not the candidate they want
they're not going to astral turf for him
they're not going to do it they're just
not going to do it they've got a stable
of candidates you've got Rama Swami that
nobody knows anything about they love
that because
they can't tie a bunch of baggage to
them right away you've got Brian Kemp
down there who's had been quiet as a
church mouse you notice he didn't get
involved in any of this they did a test
run with tiny D he failed miserably did
you see him in Japan oh my God
yeah wow and then he can't even shake a
hand and then when he was on the fox new
interview which I might show here in a
little bit and he was asked about had
handed he was asking him about
um Trump and his relationship and how it
was bad and all this and Ron Ron just he
looks such like a weak piece of [__] and
let me tell you something that's one
thing that isn't going to play well with
these moglodytes and in these cult
members is someone appearing to be weak
they they really like their strength to
be faked and pretended really well Texas
Paul yeah that's what they like they
like it to be a nice and pretend to you
know so they they feel nice and warm and
cozy inside when they believe the lie
that the right is the right is strong
wrong and and fascism is strength get
the [__] out of here with that nonsense
um speaking of Fox News and some crazy
[__] last night last night was the first
night that Tucker Carlson uh was not on
Fox News
um yay
um that's good
um go ahead and but I'm going to show a
clip here of Lauren Ingram
um and
um Paul's going to take a break for a
second I'm going to show you a clip of
Laura Ingraham see if you can make out
what the [__] she's talking about here I
can't make out what she's talking about
let's let's see if you can figure it out
so all you need to know about the
Democrats versus the Republicans today
is this
and their transition they got Liz Cheney
and ours we got Tulsi gabbard
what the [__] does that mean
okay first off transition to what what
what does she think was a train why in
the [__] are these people obsessed they
are obsessed with the word transition
absolutely [__] obsessed with it what
what the [__] transition are you talking
about and we didn't get Liz Cheney hey
Laura I don't know if you've been
watching my show but the entire time Liz
Cheney was even defending democracy at
the select committee I was crawling up
her ass and saying hey she's a [__]
fascist because Liz Cheney is a fascist
I don't even know that I mean she's a
fascist who who wants to pretend
democracy is good
but she's not on our side I don't [__]
Liz Cheney Liz Cheney can kick rocks as
far as I'm concerned I don't give a [__]
about Liz Cheney I don't know if you do
and really honestly Liz Cheney destroyed
herself so great
fantastic I mean one last Cheney is is
good to me Texas Paul the let me let me
replay this clip because this this is
some weird [__] see if you can make out
Texas Paul what she's trying to say here
this is weird stuff
so all you need to know about the
Democrats versus the Republicans today
is this
and their transition they got Liz Cheney
and ours we got Tulsi gabbard
I don't know what the [__] does that
even mean I I like I am I missing I
tweeted am I missing something here I
don't understand number one they're
obsessed with transition right and the
word transition they [__] love that
but what is she talking about we didn't
get Liz Cheney do you like are you a fan
of Liz Cheney [__] no get the [__] out
of here you can keep her all you want I
I mean she she defended democracy and I
was really surprised when her and her
dad really leaned into democracy because
they are no real fans of true democracy
they're just not they they love
plutocracy they love crony capitalism I
mean her [__] dad is the picture of
it but this idea that we got Liz Cheney
Liz Cheney's not a Democrat what are you
talking about nor is she welcome in the
Democratic party I don't know what she's
talking about and and Tulsi gabbard you
can have her you can have that with a
gymnastics what the [__] what I don't
know what she's talking about here can
you figure it out
no she's just full of [__] she just it's
it's another one it's that it's that
constant uh we're better than them
[__] that they always put out but
they they can't ever really pull up
anything where they actually are better
than us so they just create this [__]
fiction that oh they got Liz Cheney
who's terrible and we got Tulsi gabbard
who's great she's so pity you know I
mean it's just it's [__] ridiculous
nonsense is what it is it's it she might
as well have said that they got mansion
and Cinema
you know it's just
are they good she can she can have them
you can have them yeah [__]
sayonara
um speaking of speaking of this the the
women right Liz Cheney Tulsi gambard
because this is gonna be a theme folks
because here's what here's what I see
happening um because everyone knows now
today it's official that Kamala Harris
is going to be on the ticket with Biden
everyone's like oh who's he gonna
replace that stupid [__] right Kamala
Harris was always going to be on the
ticket with Biden and and I don't know
if anyone knows this she is a woman and
she is she has been a very good vice
president she's not always the best
interviewee right she's never been the
best interviewee but that's not a reason
why she can't be a good vice president
but Donald Trump is going to pick a
woman to run with him on his ticket
don't you think Texas ball
you know man I mean it would make sense
for him to do it but the problem is he's
such a toxic toxic misogynist that he
would end up saying something really
[__] stupid about her I'm so glad you
said that I'm so glad you said that and
that's exactly why that's exactly why I
see this coming from a mile away okay
here's here's what I see coming and it's
not just with these big huge
personalities like Sarah Huckabee
Sanders Kerry Lake Marjorie Taylor green
Lauren bobert these big influencers
online right I have been in spaces and
there's been several right-wing women
who keep talking about this motherhood
and mother women and pro mother right
they're using this language and the
reason why is because they know Donald
Trump is probably going to pick a woman
okay okay folks he's probably gonna pick
Carrie late that's my guess best guess
right now is that and he'll pick her
early would be the best thing that I can
decide um now it depends on if Kerry
decides to run in the U.S Senate race in
Arizona which would be a huge mistake
for her she would go ahead a hard thing
for Kerry Lake to overcome is that she
looks like Leatherface if you see her in
an actual interview she looks like
Leatherface from Texas Chainsaw Massacre
and and Donald Trump really really
really hates
ugly people right so and he's not going
to walk around in a in a soft filter all
the damn time did you see the last one
that she used on her last fox interview
they went so soft filter it looked like
somebody had smeared vaseline on the
camera lens so do you think do you think
it's someone like Kim Reynolds or
Christy gnome those governors that might
might run because he's dabbling on it
gonna pick Sarah Huckabee Sanders if
he's worried about looks for crying out
those are my beds farty March or Christy
no
who those are my two bets Christy gnome
and who else you mean
farty March the petty Eddie yeah what
you think he thinks she's good looking
come on man I mean I'm I'm I'm I'm
saying most good looks are subjective
right I mean person to person you know
it's whatever you want what whatever
floats your [__] boat I don't care if
you if you like a certain body type or
something hey I I'm more you know what
they they've been knocking on lizzo
online because she had a concert and
she's a big woman but she's beautiful
and and I I you know and she's
attractive because she's confident and
confidence is most the time uh the key
point to attraction or being attractive
but whatever floats your boat but you
think Donald Trump thinks Marjorie
Taylor green is good looking is that
what you're telling me
no I don't think these are awesome
and she's willing to say all the
outrageous [__] I see why I'm just
trying to make you defended that uh
Marjorie Taylor green is good looking in
the same sentence that's all I'm trying
to do Texas ball okay so here's here's
my theory on this and and and maybe I'm
wrong which I'm rarely ever am but
here's what I'll tell you about my
theory on this Pro mother woman thing
because they're trying to sell a
pro-woman message right but they can't
really lean into the whole Pro woman
thing Texas Paul because that will
really hurt their political image so
they gotta lean into the pro mother
thing right the motherhood you're
designed to have children you're
designed to be a mother you as a female
are designed to do what we the Christian
nationalists tell you that you are
designed to do but it's all in a guise
to um to prop up the right wing as per
woman right now it's all [__] and
when you listen to him talk and you
start poking holes in their Theory hoes
in their Theory ooh that was a huge
misstep Texas Paul someone might get me
on that uh poke holes in their Theory
it's they start to crumble and start to
fall but this is Sarah Huckabee Sanders
did you see this [__] commercial that
she ran with the real women koozie
did you see it oh my God it's hilarious
I I honestly thought it was parody at
first
I did I didn't think it was real I
thought someone was making fun of these
[__] but that's a real
commercial the right wing is so horrible
at this but here she is on Fox News
um and I don't know what show she's on
here who gives a rat's ass really but
she's trying to sell this this real
woman
Pro mother Womanhood [__] listen to what
she says here
it is absolutely insane what the left is
trying to do to women they're basically
telling people that if you wear makeup
and you shop online and you cry
sometimes then you too can be a woman
how in the [__] is that telling women
what to do what are you talking about
what the left says is hey if you want to
be a mother that's great if you want to
be a mother and you want to be a stay no
Mom if you want to have a career that's
great go ahead if you're if you're
someone who wants to transition to a
woman hey more power to you it's your
Liberty it's your life you do what you
want I live my life and I want to live
it you do it how you do it let's do this
together and let's all let's all Kumbaya
and have a quality and Equity what the
[__] the right always
uh the right I always say oh women
you're so important you're the center of
our household you are the most important
thing motherhood is the most important
thing now get back in the [__]
kitchen and make babies right well you
know this is this is an attempt to
attract the white Suburban turfs okay
that's what this is an attempt to do
um because white Suburban turfs even
though they don't like the whole uh
trans people thing and they're a little
they're a little skewed on on the facts
of what trans people are and how many
and why they're transitioning and and
just their overall experience because
it's not these these turfs experience so
they get confused a little bit right but
what I think what the right wing is
trying to do is to promote a pro mother
real Womanhood type message to attract
what would be known as the white
Suburban turfs right out there and these
turfs are going to vote for Donald Trump
and a woman on the ticket and Carrie
Lake can be the picture of this
Womanhood or maybe even maybe even one
of these women on these beer cans which
we see that Kim Reynolds and Christy
gnome is on these these beer koozies
should I show the should I show the uh
the commercial do you want to see that
yeah go ahead man yeah I mean I I would
love chances are most folks in our
audience haven't seen it I mean it
wasn't targeted towards us let's um
God I can't even believe this [__] is
[__] real but it is uh and I was
gonna show it the other day but I ran
out of time you know how it goes when
you only got two cars
yeah well let me see if I can find this
on [__] it's been a couple days you
know this stuff moves like crazy now on
Twitter you can't find [__] over there
did you have you noticed that you can't
find [__]
um
I don't know maybe I'm off my rocker
here
you know the other day there was a tweet
put out by Midas that I sent to myself
texted it to myself
I was online didn't have my phone with
me so I was sitting at my laptop tried
to find that text
could not find it just could not it was
did not exist well maybe maybe they
deleted it
later on I got my phone opened up my
text boom went right to it I mean
I'm telling you Twitter's a
clusterfucker it's a dumpster fire
speaking of dumpster fires here's this
commercial now when you watch this I'm
telling you now you already know that
it's real because I've told you but when
I first watched it I wasn't sure if it
was real or not
um but well just watch
America presents real women of politics
[Music]
We Salute all the real woman leaders of
this great country real women don't have
to fake it real women
doing real things real women
some big companies can't tell the
difference between real and fake anymore
real people know the difference that's
why we're introducing the real women of
politics koozie
now you can salute the real women of
politics in every Backyard Barbecue and
tailgate
and if it covers up the label of a big
woke company oh my God it will
that works too
[Music]
I want to give you some insights order
your real women go ahead you know the
Disney thing the inbev anzizer bush
thing and this that and the other if
it'll cover up the label of a big woke
company
that is actually something that gets we
don't get it on the left they don't
Target it to us but they pump it out on
the left or on the right like crazy that
companies are woke that's part of the
whole woke thing that's why they went
after Disney that's why they went after
these there's a group of billionaire
oligarchs that have come up with a
message messaging system to say your
racism is okay your hate is okay they're
taking your freedom Away by making you
accept people when nobody's making you
do [__] but this whole
cover-up companies thing they're going
after corporations because corporations
have over the last you know we had a big
movement as far as the lgbtq community
is out there that that companies would
say okay you can't be hateful to gay
people
you know right it was just it was an HR
thing you know they're trying to roll
that back their message is that if a
company like inbev or whatever
says hey you you know LGBT TQ people
we're going to sell them some beer and
let them go live their best lives you
can hate them for that
you can hate them for that and more so
they're attacking you and your
americanism
by trying to take your right to hate
away right because that's what they're
really saying is we have the right to
hate which they do have the right to
hate and frankly I I hope they keep
yelling and screaming the things that
they hate in their bigotry out loud
because then we know who they are right
and we know what they stand for this is
this is how we spot it this is how we
how we get rid of it in our government
yeah you've gotta you've got a troll
right now that's just trying to uh uh
mimic that I can't find them now uh we
was talking about what's woke gay uh
yeah see I mean that that's the message
they're being fed over there right
well so so
here's what I'll tell you about this
this Koozie commercial because um I
don't know if they hired some satirist
to do this commercial but like if I was
gonna do a commercial to make fun of
Sarah Huckabee Sanders that's the exact
commercial I would have done and the
reason why is because
is at one point they're like cover up
the label of a woke company I'm like so
your ideas that I don't want I don't I
it's not that I don't want to drink woke
beer but I don't want people I don't
want my friends to know that I drink
woke beer like what like again I had
this stupid [__] debate in a Twitter
space the other day about Bud Light and
their brand and how these right Wingers
think that bud light's gonna go away and
there's not gonna be a Bud Light anymore
like you people are [__] dumb number
one you don't know how to Beer Market
Works number two you don't know anything
about beer brands if and if you did know
something on beer brands you would know
that Bud Light isn't going anywhere for
the next two or three decades at least
at least I mean but the narrative oh go
ahead you got to remember they don't
live in reality Tony right the narrative
to them is they were strong and they
told this big company where it could go
and now they're cow in town and they did
you got to give them this much inbev
bent over and took it they did
fired the executives I I disagree with
you there I disagree with there because
they they actually put the per the one
woman who was on uh who who actually was
responsible for this um this internet
influencer ad because uh Anheuser-Busch
spends a lot of money in influencer
advertising now what it is is it's niche
market advertising where they niche
market to large audiences like Dylan
Mulvaney's and other influencers not
just trans people but also right-wingers
too they use right-wing influencer to
put their brand in these influencers
videos now that woman is on paid leave
but but the CEO statement was so weak
and it was so uh didn't take a side at
all and if they were cheering that
statement from the CEO I hate that I
hate to give I'd hate to tell him this
but that was just to appease anyone who
wanted a statement that was it that was
it it was so weak it didn't mention any
of the communities specifically that
were involved in the back and forth on
the canceling or not canceling that CEO
was putting out a statement because they
were pressured to put out a statement
and it was and they know that bud
light's going to live on and the one
reason why they know this Texas ball
it's because they have huge contracts
and these people have to file these
contracts including Kid Rock Kid Rock
was the one who set this whole thing off
when he was shooting up I don't know
five or six cases of beer with his with
his rifle but the thing is is Kid Rock
owns a bar in Nashville where he sells a
ton of Bud Light a [__] ton of it and
he can't take it off the [__] shelves
because he's he's contractually
obligated to to sell Bud Light in his
bar the only way Kid Rock wasn't gonna
was gonna separate himself from woke
Anheuser-Busch was to close down his bar
and he's not going to do that so I I
I'll I'll tell you that I think that and
I told them this in the space the other
day that this whole [__] [__]
about Bud Light all these people making
these Tic Tacs and these social media
videos saying oh you go woke you go
broke I'm not buying Bud lighting
anymore they're do it's it's it's
[__] cruelty for clout folks that's
all it is because as soon as that person
goes and dumps those beers into the
trash can they're gonna keep drinking
Bud Light they like Bud like that's
their [__] beer they'll just get a
real woman of politics Koozie to cover
up the Bud Light labels that way but
Tony you're you're kind of missing one
thing there I agree with you 100 what
you're saying but what you're missing is
that you live in reality
how many people did you have I had to
correct so many people that were telling
me that Bud Light stock was tanking well
one it's not Bud Light stock it's inbev
Anheuser-Busch and I would objectively
show them I could okay here's the here's
the stock ticker no it's actually going
up it has been for the last six months
that's what stocks do go up and down but
they they would sit there and they would
say things and these people don't have
to live in reality you've got to
understand they don't have to as long as
they believe it they're okay with it
there you know how many people did you
see that were saying oh yeah we showed
Anheuser-Busch that's why they made this
apology that was really not an apology
but they said it was an apology because
they lost eight billion dollars in net
worth no they didn't I can show you the
stock but it doesn't matter Tony you
know who lost all they have to have is
the narrative you're strong your hate is
good it's okay them damn liberals can't
tell you nothing you yeah but that's my
point though is that it's all fake it's
all fraudulent it's all lies so it
doesn't really live in any kind of
reality at all I mean yeah are there
people out there that are going to
believe that that Bud Light is woke beer
yeah sure absolutely until they go to
the bar and they watch all their buddies
because Texas Paul you know this living
in a manga area everything is based on
affiliation and third party confirmation
if if that guy who dumped all his beer
out and bought Coors beer which is gay
or beer than Bud Light by their standard
and and now he goes to the bar and all
his buddies are drinking Bud Light he's
like what are you drinking Bud Light for
like ah that was just the thing on the
internet who gives a [__] I like Bud
Light he's going to drink a Bud Light
that's just how it's gonna work I don't
care what I don't care what they want to
do what they want to say what they're
going to try to do it's not gonna work
just like Disney Disney doesn't give two
shits if Ron DeSantis wants to go to war
with it they don't give a [__] they
don't care it's not gonna affect their
brand or what what they're doing they're
not going to change their marketing
strategy based on some bonehead trying
to [__] alter up some crazy reality
that doesn't exist Anheuser-Busch does
not care about lies and [__] on the
internet what they care about is people
buying [__] beer that's what they
care about and there's one thing that
Anheuser-Busch specifically who is a
subsidiary of invent knows more than
anything that anything that any company
on Earth knows probably right right
after or right before Coca-Cola and they
know how to Market a brand that's one
thing they know how to do and I'm
telling you Bud Light ain't going
anywhere just like Coca-Cola didn't go
anywhere even after its debacle in the
80s when it came out with with Coke and
they had to go to classic Coke it's just
not going to happen
it's not because it's all Wise It's all
trumped up [__] on the internet
excuse the pun
yeah I I agree with you Anheuser-Busch
isn't going anywhere because they're
really good at what they do but
will they hurt Bud Light sales yeah
because if they keep repeating the
fiction enough it becomes reality for
these folks and like I said I'm already
having to deal with people that aren't
in reality that are saying really stupid
[__] like man did you see inbev stock
just go well they're saying Bud Light
stock and they have no [__] clue that
Bud Light is just a brand not a company
um you know they believe that and so
when it gets to the bar they're going to
be like oh give me another give me this
give me that anything but a Bud Light
they're just not going to do it you know
and it's working to a degree Tony it
doesn't work when light shines on it
when you and I do what we do and we we
tell the truth and we say uh yeah that's
[__] here's the stock price you know
it doesn't work in the real world
but it keeps them control of the
Republican party and there are a group
of people Tony that are behind this
that are behind this and they really
think and that's why Vivek ramaswamy
is so important to watch because you've
seen him do it he comes out and says
things that are provably false about
civil rights about anything just [__]
provably false but he ends the sentence
with that's just history that's just
fact
he's going to get that core that wants
to believe their racism is great
everything's okay and they're going to
say yeah that's just fact and then you
and I are going to have to sit here and
play whack a [__] mole with these
idiots that are sitting here repeating
his stupid [__] and pulling up data and
everything else oh God damn when he's
got their course their core people
together and in the meantime we've got
[__] [__] oyger
you know sitting here shooting Us in the
ass
trying to make a buck
and all our ships aren't sailing in the
same [__] Direction all right well
you know that's that's the goal Tony
that is the goal so Discord over here
and keep them Goose marching together
like [__] Nazis over there
someone's laughing at whack-a-mole
um DK Hall I you know what I think we
should change it officially to wakamaga
you know because it's always the Maga
there you go you're always trying I'm
always trying to whack a Maga right it's
not a mole anymore
um speaking of trying to get in One
Direction here is the um here's the ad
that Joe Biden put out this morning and
it's about three minutes long watch it
in his entirety Texas Paul's reaction
here on the other side
foreign
[Music]
personal freedom is fundamental to who
we are as Americans there's nothing more
important nothing more sacred that's
been the work of my first term to fight
for our democracy it shouldn't be a red
Revolution
to protect our rights to make sure that
everyone in this country is treated
equally and that everyone is given a
fair shot at making it
but you know around the country Maggie
extremists are lining up to take on
those Bedrock freedoms cutting Social
Security that you've paid for your
entire life while cutting taxes for the
very wealthy dictating what health care
decisions women can make Banning books
and telling people who they can love all
while I'm making it more difficult for
you to be able to vote
[Music]
when I ran for president four years ago
I said we're in a battle for the soul of
America and we still are
the question we're facing is whether in
the years ahead we have more freedom or
less freedom more rights are fewer
I know what I want the answer to be and
I think you do too
this is not a time to be complacent
[Music]
that's why I'm running for reelection
because I know America
I know we're good and decent
people I know we're still a country that
believes in honesty and respect of
treating each other with dignity
That We're a nation where we give hate
no Safe Harbor we believe that everyone
is equal that everyone should be given a
fair shot to succeed
us
[Music]
every generation Americans have faced
the moment
stand up for our personal freedom stand
up for the right to vote in our civil
rights
[Music]
and this is our moment
smoking
so if you're with me go to joebiden.com
let's finish this job I know we can
because this is the United States of
America there's nothing simply nothing
we cannot do if we go together
[Music]
so there it is Texas ball let's finish
the job hey I got someone else joining
us here Gabe Sanchez finally made it in
hey yeah you know yeah well gotta deal
with clients what were you taking a [__]
yeah it was a very long one I gotta tell
you that like it was huge it was one I
had to call in I had to call him back up
I had to call him the team here's the
whole thing I need a lot of I needed a
lot of emotional and physical support to
really get that one through that happens
sometimes
listen if you ever need somebody to hold
your hand when you're in the [__] oh
don't call me oh don't call me damn I
was hoping that was the love that I
needed that support you know gave it
have you seen this commercial I have it
is
Texas Paul hasn't so I wanted to see I
wanted to see if you had so I want to
get Texas fall reaction first I
apologize I know I just brought you in
from a fresh wipe but I want to get
Texas Paul's uh reaction because he
hasn't seen it first so go ahead get
give me two reactions to it yeah
from our perspective that's an
outstanding ad that's a really good ad
it really is a really good ad
from the rights perspective and I've
just come out of that freaking Rabbit
Hole over there
right Wingers looked at that ad and say
black person black person black person
like they didn't see a single white
person in there on that ad look how many
black people are in there yeah that's
what they're going to say they're
putting that [__] in our face they're
shoving it down our throat
that's what the right Wing's response to
that ad with that's fantastic I think uh
Gabe what was your reaction to the end
well I'm I'm curious I haven't looked at
I haven't looked up who made the ad yet
right because I was curious who was
behind this one and I gotta say there's
oh you wrote it or who produced it no
who produced it right because a lot of
that stuff is like you know footage that
was done you know him talking head but
then a lot of that is footage that they
probably had from uh from on the road
and so my question is like was that made
internally or was that made from a
third-party Ad Agency you know either
way I think it was done very well right
right from the beginning to the end you
know talking directly to America showing
moments where he's engaging with
Americans showing moments where
you know he's hit certain Milestones
certain bills that were passed or uh
things that were signed or you know
nominating and and confirming you know
Supreme Court Judge right without
actually having to say it right exactly
right and it goes to you know Texas
Paul's point which is like
certain people white people racist
whatever feeling like that's you know
just like oh my God I'm gonna freak out
over a can that actually isn't in
circulation kind of thing and get all in
my feels it's the same thing here it's
not shoved in your face it's saying look
this is what we accomplished together if
we work together we can do a lot and
this is what I was able to do
despite all of the political roadblocks
that were ahead of us and that were in
front of us during the last couple years
right every step of the way we've always
had Republicans say nope not gonna
happen
and despite that Joe Biden has
successfully passed certain bills uh you
know given assistance to Americans
um put forward you know progressed our
country forward like we have we still
have a long way to go and a lot to work
on
but if there's any indication of what
the last couple years have been and what
we've accomplished you know the
confidence is there to say another four
years with Joe Biden is something that
I feel good about you know right so here
here well my first reaction was this
um because there is and I know this
sounds ridiculous but this shows um how
Democrats are really trying to reach
folks um you notice this ad is is
vertical and they had a horizontal
version and a vertical version but this
is the actual version that Joe Biden
posted on his account on Twitter now the
other thing that I think is important is
it's got 4.2 million views already uh
this morning yesterday I think the Ron
DeSantis bobblehead video
got like six six or seven million views
so far
um so those two videos Rhonda Sant is
doing the bobble head and this ad from
Joe Biden which is uh a magnificent ad
by the way
um and there's I I can name 100
different reasons why in the advice
Brendan Lewis's comment right there if
you would uh Brendan Lewis it just just
scrolled up
okay
um but I thought I thought that it uh
let's see I don't see it there Gabe can
you see if you can find this one
yeah that one
this this is exactly what is being
pushed in the right wing uh poor poor
exactly your hate Brendan Lewis's hate
is America you can't make him not hate
and by running this ad with black folks
in it or or being okay with just gay
people lgbtq community that's going on
and living their best life
well you're doing something to Brendan
you're saying he's not good
well you're not good Brendan you're a
[__] [__] and a you're an idiot
piece of [__] and we're never gonna stop
saying it hey a great day Brendan
Brendan make sure you subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast please please come
here maybe you'll learn a thing or two
if you keep listening every day for two
hours maybe you'll learn about how how
queer we are over here on the Democratic
side maybe I drink a lot of game beer
I'll tell you that much well it is
something a lot of gay woke ass beer is
what I do I'm very secure in my
sexuality Brendan so I don't need to um
I don't need to be scared about someone
else's
um but I will say that I think it's
significant that that they formatted
this on social media to be vertical and
I know that sounds a little [__]
weird like really Tony is that but but
it it I'm telling you more if you listen
to the messaging right if you break down
the script and just write it out and put
it on a piece of paper and go through it
and line by line and then and you watch
this show they're starting to catch on
to the messaging they're starting to
catch on to the narrative folks and and
I know that it's been a long time and
the White House still has a lot of work
to do to get on message and to get on
narrative to track more and more people
even people like Brendan who don't
realize that they're not only fighting
for lgbtq communities uh rights and
Liberty but at the same time they're
defending yours too to be straight and
CIS and a white man and like everyone
has Liberty you have Liberty dummy but
that's why I've
two messages going forward yeah
objectively take people like Brendan
Lewis in reality he came on your show he
made that [__] comment we are better
than them that's message number one we
are better human beings everybody in
this audience listen to what I am
telling you because it is objectively
the truth you are a better human being
than Brendan Lewis you are a better
American than Brendan Lewis message
number two
you want Brendan Lewis to go to go away
forever
vote Democrat and vote the Republican
party out of existence and all this
drama dies period
the other thing I want to point out is
like just from a like my experience in
marketing and working on different ad
campaigns this is one where
there is a collection uh of moments that
have happened over time throughout this
presidency this Administration and
there's also a lot of connection that's
made between me as the viewer right and
one of those steps is obviously make it
in a vertical format which is like where
you things you know shorts and Tick Tock
and Instagram and you're like
you're you're reaching out to the
demographic that's going to consume it
in that format right
and also you just know that those those
shorter segments those formats are going
to be shared more more often because
that's just how those platforms uh
prioritize those formats right
but beyond that the messaging that's in
there right it's one thing
sorry sorry I I gotta I gotta clean up
something I gotta clean up something
because Mighty librarian says it best
here she says best chat fam ever okay
um casmo says sarcasm rarely translates
over text I think Brendan was giving us
his uh his Maga version of what the
response of the ad would be yeah uh
Terry Tracy Rose says Brandon Lewis
wasn't trolling he was joking
um uh foggy Ozark says Brandon was
getting Christ on a crutch hey hang on
hang on I'm not done uh Captain turns
his sarcasm folks and Brendan says I
have a gay daughter Brendan Brendan I'm
glad you're here I'm glad you're here
and I'm glad you're sarcastic and to be
quite honest even if you were a manga
I'd want you here or if you weren't I'd
want you here rather you're sarcastic or
serious but what Texas Paul is trying to
show you and and me and Gabe have been
saying it for a long time is that these
people are parodies and satires of
themselves just like I showed you the
[__] stupid Koozie commercial if if
you're not gonna over say LOL or with
the lamp face or something okay why
don't why don't we do this yeah right I
feel like this is the way because
obviously yes over
I wasn't sure how to take Dem queers I
was like it could be could be serious I
don't know okay yes uh Brendan hello
[__] I'll just clarify this all
right here is how we fix the situation
going forward if you because obviously
again to Tony's Point like sarcasm is
dead uh uh parody is six feet under for
it has been for years
why don't if if someone says something
that is intended to be taken
sarcastically
uh put like um the upside down smiley
face yeah put the yeah there we go put
the upside down smiley face after the
comment so that nobody takes it nobody
in the chat or no one uh either
ourselves or a guest takes it the wrong
way
because Brent and Brendan I I I it
doesn't matter to me what your what Your
political affiliation is you you know
here on the Tony Michaels podcast and I
am open to manga coming well I I believe
that we're working there's several hate
Watchers that come watch our show every
day that we're working on converting uh
to Liberty and liberalism and knowing
that liberalism is the strength so I
appreciate your sarcasm and we do have
the best audience in the world and
Brendan you're a part of it rather
rather you're whether you're being
sarcastic or not so
um Texas Paul watch what I want to
apologize to Brendan I really do go
ahead go ahead go ahead Brendan
I am sorry for foisting you up on that
patard when you were making a sarcastic
comment the real problem is Brendan that
the way right Wingers actually are it
was impossible to tell that it was a
sarcastic
comment
and that's the point so everything we
said still applies just let style stop
hating on Brendan okay
he's calling you a dumbass and it's
right you [__] mother [__] your gay
daughter [__] everybody in your entire
[__] lemon juice lineage you [__]
dickwad [__] I just apologize to
you be a decent [__] human being and
take the [__] apology you [__] better
[__] punch that [__] right in
the goddamn throat uh someone says let's
let's go Brendan all right all right all
right enough enough okay back to the
video back to the video we all love
Brendan we all love Brendan now
I I believe that this video is going to
get millions of views online and the one
reason why I think it's going to get
millions of views is because they put it
in the vertical platform and Gabe
Sanchez I know that sounds stupid but
I'm correct in this am I not yeah I
didn't say it was stupid oh God damn it
the [__] delay again uh I didn't say
it was stupid at all I think like the
one the one of the points I was trying
to make was the the administration is is
making an effort to reach a demographic
that would most likely consume it in
this format a younger demographic
um and I think it's I mean it's a small
it's an incremental change right it
might seem trivial at first but the way
in which it circulates and the way in
which it's digested
it makes sense to do it that way
right well and and not only that is that
these videos it is three minutes long
which I'm gonna tell I would tell them
that was the wrong choice because it is
three minutes long what did I say
incremental changes you know it's small
put it put it put it in 60 seconds Biden
and white house and I understand this is
an announcement so I hope they go
forward using the same format using the
same tone with shorter videos in the
vertical format but I'll tell you one
thing about the um the imagery in this
in this though and and the wording
um is the dark days ahead of time right
so there was this there's this bong bong
bong in the very beginning which kind of
spells out what fascism is knocking on
the front door right
um which I think is beautiful I say that
all the time fascism is not it's almost
like whoever did this ad is watching
this show and then he goes into this
talk about freedom and how democracy was
being protected and that was the reason
why and who he's protecting it from
which is Maga extremist he says it write
out loud in this ad he doesn't hide it
he's not hiding it in the sauce or
something he's like there are some
Republicans or some [__] like that he's
like no the Maga extremists and and the
reason why he's doing that Texas Paul is
because he knows who he's going to run
against he knows it's going to be Trump
that's what they're betting on do you
see that in this ad that he's betting
it's going to be Trump as the nominee
yeah I think everybody pretty much will
thinks that Trump's going to steamroll
this attempt to to squeeze him out I
mean he he just has the base he does I
mean and and I don't see a hat trick
where they take the base away from him
you know and we're doing Trump a favor
because you know when we're doing the
right thing by indicting him and
everything else man that makes them want
to just grab onto him even tighter
um because they're shitty people they're
just lousy human beings so yeah I I
absolutely believe that this is
definitely aimed at Trump
um but I also think that if you if you
look at the general themes of it
this this could apply to Brian Kemp this
could apply to Bill Lee this could apply
to you know and you've got Billy you saw
it the other day governor of Tennessee
Billy trying to like walk put some [__]
back in the horse saying oh we ought to
have red flag laws and you know enhanced
in Tennessee he's trying to walk it back
a little bit because this cannon that
Joe Joe Biden's using man it's it's not
it's not a [__] sniper rifle it is a
massive
Battleship sized freaking shotgun that
that blows away just about every
candidate in the in the Republican party
it really does but yeah I feel you I do
think it was aimed directly at Trump and
I do think we're going to end up
God help us with another Trump campaign
well I mean I I think we are and the
other thing that I think he's betting on
is when you put the Social Security part
in there of course Trump is talking
about cutting Social Security before so
he's going to be able to pin that on
Trump but I think that's the one little
thing he put in there just in case maybe
just maybe Ron DeSantis doesn't flop
here which I think he's done I think
Ron's done but but maybe when they were
making this ad they that the the bobble
head motor
hadn't happened yet um because I I you
know I'll be honest with you it should
be Ron desantis's vile
um position on Women's Health Care his
vile position on on Banning books his
vile position on on race and woke is and
whatever his his [__] fascist beliefs
are that should be enough to kill his
campaign but uh it's obviously not the
bobblehead thing is going to kill it um
I I'm I'm expecting that next week we'll
see a trump ad with the bobblehead
moment in it um and it'll absolutely
throw the last the last shovel of dirt
on Rhonda santis and his his effort to
start a campaign here
um and he he he'll maybe back down and
won't actually attempt to change the law
in Florida where he can run okay um we
got 20 about 20 minutes left
I just want to point out I just want to
point out uh I'm delayed though again
God damn it yeah of course I gotta fix
this [__] anyway uh there's love from
Brendan to Texas Paul
this happened you know what this is you
know what I'll just say this this
happens with [__] family right we
[__] want to choke each other and we
get into a fight and we resolved that
[__]
real time [__] right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast Brendan we uh we love
you yeah it it it and again I I I love
all the audience regardless of even if
you hate me are you love to hate me I
don't give a [__] I love you you're here
every day that's what gives me the
algorithm that's what gives me the
ability to pump my message out and
you're hearing it that's more important
to me so Brandon I'm glad you're here
every day and um you know what you can
do to make sure that you're not
identified as troll put a picture on
your profile on your avatar that'll
that'll help that'll help okay so I I've
got a clip here because yesterday Tucker
Carlson got fired and it's almost like
it's gone it's old news it's [__] old
oh no no no no no
the details are [__] coming out now
okay let's hear what the details are now
I'm gonna show you this Donald Trump
video where he's yeah yeah
um so what the delay the delay just made
that way funnier by the way the uh the
the details that seem to be coming out
and they're they're you know they're
people talking right and it's coming out
so you have to be confirmed but
basically what I've been reading is
uh they're firing Tucker Carlson for
just cause so Murdoch is trying to get
out of paying Tucker Carlson the
remaining portion of his salary which
from what I understand was up for
negotiation for a new contract through
2029.
the second thing is it sounds like
uh
Rupert Murdoch watched this happen live
remotely
so when he was fired he was watching not
from the actual office or that it was
happening from his home he's like 200
million dollar mansion or whatever it is
yeah so you you're telling me wasting
because this is the image I'm getting in
my head you're telling me Rupert Murdoch
woke up yesterday morning he's like I'm
gonna fire that [__] so he's
like get him on a live chat and he's
sitting there in his robe eating like
his oatmeal and his yogurt
um and he's sitting there in his [__]
robe in some kind of like another bag
I don't see it as that what I see
happening is
they knew it was going to happen right
so yeah he wears the robe he sits in a
leather chair however what's actually
happened is he's not on a public Zoom
call he's watching from some security
camera that's in the in the corner of
the room just like what maniacally
they didn't even Zoom him in he's he's
standing there watching their reactions
in person absolutely he's gonna watch
his son and yesterday though do it
himself but yeah but yesterday though
they said um that Murdoch personally
fired him himself but what you're saying
is now the reports are he just ordered
the firing and he what I understand is
the firing happened and the firing
didn't happen in person so he could have
been there to fire him or on the call to
fire but he wasn't the one who was there
in person mad Max's Rupert is a hairless
cat hey easy on offending hairless cats
okay we've already offended enough
people in the chat today don't don't
offend hairless cats okay but no I I
mean he probably was I can see him in
like a red silk robe right with it half
open yeah and and just wait give me a
sec I'll be right back hold on okay and
and I get Texas ball I can see Rupert
sitting in his leatherback chair with
his red silk robe on with his hairless
nasty you know skeleton chest hanging
out and he's watching the security
footage eating his oatmeal and his
yogurt going
can't you see it like Mr Burns type [__]
right
yeah I kind of pictured like a a Star
Wars
um you know like Darth Vader or or the
Emperor Palpatine hooked up to all this
[__] equipment keeping him alive and
he's just you know nasty old gray you
know
but then
anyways it's actually kind of
interesting what what Gabe's was talking
about about how uh they're using Abby
grossberg's lawsuit as the reason for
his firing so they don't have to pay
Tucker out I mean he he really screwed
the pooch on that one and I I don't
believe he has a leg to stand on he can
turn around and try to sue but well do
you think though do you think though
that they're not gonna I mean I was in
the space yesterday
um and I wasn't even I think I spoke for
a minute or two but anyway it's hard to
keep track of when I speak and I mean
when I don't but um they were talking a
lot
about this yesterday and one person
brought up a good point
that they're gonna give Tucker a golden
parachute so he doesn't go out there and
yell and scream right I mean I I you
know and he does he isn't out there
talking about it
um because if Tucker Carlson's out there
talking about it that's not going to be
bad that's going to be horrible for Fox
News Now
I believe that they're probably using
whatever they can use because Rupert
Murdoch is a piece of [__] let's face it
they're using whatever they can do to
get rid of Tucker in that 8 PM slot and
one thing is this is the Dominion
settlement but the what the actual [__]
is going on the other thing is
[Laughter]
would you say would you say that Rupert
Murdoch was dressed like this oh God
damn well I mean he would have his
hairless nasty chest out but yeah right
right yeah I don't know I feel like this
is that's almost yeah you know you're a
little you're a little young to the look
though you need to look about a thousand
you don't think that you don't you don't
think that Rupert Murdoch has like a
blood boy you know that he's getting
that oh yeah he's been able to stay
alive so I feel like he's got a kid off
to the side and he's like give me that
blood boy you know and and or you know I
don't actually know how he's I've never
actually heard Rupert Murdoch speak
before so I don't know how he talks
old Australian he's an Australian man
he's an Australian but he's [__]
Scottish so he talks like a [__]
Scottish Australian a Scottish
Australian yeah I guess that's a thing
okay well speaking of [__] um
defending Tucker Carlson here's Donald
Trump Jr really honest honestly gave the
thing that I I picked up on the on the
Twitter space yesterday is the right
doesn't know how to juxtap's position
with the Tucker thing nope they're not
real sure well yeah I mean all they know
is is that they they want someone in the
8 PM slot that's gonna be a Putin
propaganda right and I think that's what
Rupert is trying to back away from is to
get he want he didn't give a [__] about
Tucker he wants that 8 pm he wants the
creative control of that APM slot back
but let's listen to Don Junior's take
I'm sure it's a magnificent one again
he's one of the few people pushing those
boundaries one of the few people uh you
know actually speaking to Independence
and across the aisle uh and winning them
over with facts logic and reason
who's he talking about he's talking to
Charlie Kirk about Tucker Carlson this
is some wild ass [__] Texas fall I mean
man I tell you what we live in the
weirdest of times just the
where where Don Jr can go on Charlie
Kurt's show and say that Tucker Carlson
is one of the one one of the only ones
out there attracting Independence and
Democrats with truth and facts what are
you [__] is this real life is this or
is this some sort of AI
um um anomaly here that has been I tell
you it's it's really amazing to watch
because one of the things I was reading
in this morning was a National Review
um and they were Finn
did to himself was their story and it's
gone now I mean it is gone uh tuck all
they have is a story that says Tucker
was let go by Fox the story yesterday
was Tucker did this to himself you know
nobody did this to Tucker
um it's amazing to see that this the the
political machination machinations that
are going on and it makes me wonder
where you know at first I just thought
Tucker was going to end up on the
breadline you know with Glenn Beck doing
his his own independent [__] on on on
uh the internet but you know I don't
know man I don't know this is going to
be interesting as hell to watch I mean
because like I said you've got Charlie
Kirk out there and the rest of the the
propagandists out there just screaming
you can't do this to Tucker and I it
makes me wonder if Fox might end up
doing what they did on January 6th where
they were like okay we're going to tell
the truth about the election and then
they got they started to panic because
they were losing viewership
and then they went back to lying about
the election that's what got him in so
much trouble with smartmatic and
Dominion I'm wondering if this isn't
what they're trying to do again at Fox
well you know the um the other thing too
is all these right-wing media heads like
Ben Shapiro was defending Tucker of
course of course Charlie was and and all
these all these um quote unquote I call
them traitor TV news networks but all
these manga networks out there they want
Tucker on their platform I think news
nation and Russian TV RT were one of the
first ones to reach out to Tucker
officially trying to attract him and and
I said yesterday when it happened like
15 minutes after it happened I said in
the first 30 minutes that news nation is
going to go after this [__] and
everyone in the comments like what the
hell is news Nation I'm like that's
where [__] Chris Cuomo is that's
where Bill O'Reilly is they paint
themselves up as some sort of non-biased
straight down the middle news
organization and it's not it's [__]
right wing news it's right-wing talking
points it's all dressed up as oh oh it's
we're we're just moderate that's all we
are we're just trying to give you the
cold hard facts no you're not no you're
not you're [__] you're pumping a
right-wing message
um but good liars post a lot of videos
as well as Walter Masterson but this one
was great and they and I think they
tweeted it um
and said something about um
um that this is what Tucker has done to
people's brains
um and this this is the [__] truth
this is this is a wild interaction which
is really good at this I love these guys
yes have you have you do you see this
guy's shirt
holy [__] like if you see it look right
like if this guy approached you in
public with that shirt on like I'd be
like this Alpha [__] right like what
the hell what is that well let's listen
to what kind of ideas are behind the
shirt let's listen tits are coming in
dressed up as cats with collars and
leashes on and ears and supposed to have
litter boxes in the restrooms that's
incredible and you've you've seen this
I have not personally seen it but uh I
know people that are involved
with uh the schools do you ever
personally seen it I've personally seen
it no okay because that sounds
but he believes it yeah I know but if
you talk to the students
they even say that it's been going on
and uh have you you've talked to the
students and they they said they saw it
something I was saying about Bud Light
yeah
students dresses cats yes and that they
said that there had to be litter boxes
in the high schools in the bathrooms
they have to have litter boxes
unbelievable it's almost
I can't believe it
yeah it's it's kind of hard to believe
this country's so [__] dumb man well
Jesus Christ again like Texas Paul said
earlier it's not that they're dumb they
want to believe this stuff yeah but you
there's a certain level of intelligence
where you accept that as your reality
like I'm not calling everyone dumb and
I'm not you know trying to stereotype or
anything I'm just saying there is a
certain demographic a certain group of
people that support Donald Trump who are
very susceptible very gullible very open
minded in a bad way to all of the lies
the misinformation the conspiracies
anything to justify their deranged
reality that they believe or they exist
in so if you hear someone
say something you know or if they hear
someone say something it's all
confirmation bias right it says oh well
they just said that one thing I needed
to hear and that was the buzzword and I
know exactly that these beers are making
us gay or that these litter boxes are in
the classrooms right or whatever it
might be and Tucker Carlson is one of
the worst contributors the accelerants
to this issue right and so when Donald
Trump Jr says oh he's the one who's
bringing facts and he's he's the one
who's bringing truth to these
Independents and converting people over
it's almost like Donald Trump Jr is
actively not well I don't know I
actually don't know if downtown Jr knows
how to read so you know it's hard to say
if he's actively uh not reading the
headlines or if he's unwilling to
you know like his father except uh
fault or guilt or admit that he's wrong
right but they continue to push these
lies on these crazy Fringe networks like
Ben Shapiro Charlie Kirk you know well
but and and I guess the point is is that
Tucker Carlson has the most eyeballs
right that's kind of the point here's
that National Review you sent it to me
Texas Paul I can barely bring it up
because National Review not only do they
want me to subscribe and allow them to
to yeah they put it behind a paywall to
cover it up but here it says no one did
this detector and you can see remove the
paywall
um if I want to get unlimited access to
this right-wing Nazi rag no thank you
that would I'm okay but it says no one
did this to Tucker Carlson
um now as far as no you can read this
if you click the arrow I don't want to
read it oh okay well then never mind
it's National Review it's trash I think
I think the only thing that that Texas
Paul was trying to uh to point out is
that even National Review is reversing
course from their narrative yesterday
and and the reason why is because the
right wing is is circling the wagons
with Tucker Carlson that guy that you
just saw that believes that their kids
identifying as kittens going to school
in furry outfits and [__] in Cat
boxes
they want to believe they've been told
by their their oligarch Mainline [__]
news source the Tucker Carlson's a
victim here
and National Review said oh [__] okay
well we can't defend Fox on this we're
going to go ahead and just roll with the
flow because [__] crazy Guy believes
it you know right and that's a problem
folks I mean this guy also believes that
anheuser-buschock went in the tank it
didn't you know this guy believes all
kinds of crazy [__] and it doesn't
matter you know yeah what game is saying
is absolutely true light is the best
disinfectant when it when their [__]
Rams up against our bulwark it crumbles
but this [__] guy will still believe
it he will still believe it there's also
I I know you're gonna play this video
but after we should play the Walter one
of him downtown New York
talking to people about Fox News pull
that up pull that up um because I'm
gonna play our buddy Tennessee Brando
wrote a song Yesterday for Tucker that I
want to play because I think it's a
banger
um Tennessee Brando has been rolling out
these bangers as this news hits every
time one of these right winger steps on
a rake let them meet rake as we say here
um so he he did this he did this video
about Tucker but before I showed up I
want to say about Tucker Carlson
um and the reason I think the right wing
is circling wagons around him is because
they know that this is the end of
Tucker's Reign that that the eight
o'clock spot folks listen to me when I
tell you this the reason why Bill
O'Reilly was huge is because of the
eight o'clock spot on Fox News when he
when he left that eight o'clock spot no
one even [__] knows that Bill
O'Reilly's alive okay yeah Tucker
Carlson leaves this spot what everyone
knows is that's the end that's the end
of Tucker Carlson because it's not the
personality it's not the person in the
spot it's that so many people are
watching that eight o'clock spot on Fox
News and and it's because it's habit
it's what they want if and they have to
feed the audience what it wants to keep
them watching and they're going to
continue to do it they're going to find
someone else that'll sell these people
just utter complete or [__] to keep them
eating it at the eight o'clock spot and
uh
believe you me whoever they put in that
eight o'clock spot permanently we will
be showing Clips to their dumb asses
over and over and over again on this
show because people are watching it and
they're saying the dumbest stupid lies
that you can come up that they can come
up with over Fox News to feed to these
[__] morons because these morons
that's what they live off of is lies
they live off lies but let's they
certainly aren't liking the uh the kill
Mead replacement right now it's
hilarious to watch by the way yeah well
absolutely but let's listen to Tennessee
Brando's uh song here and tell tell
Tucker bye bye bow tie let's listen all
right guys did you really think I'd let
Tucker Carlson leave Fox News and not
write a song about it I call this one
bye bye bowtie
[Music]
[__] you
[__] you talk [__] it's time to hit the
road you push their propaganda son you
really a soldier soul
let's see
there's a sucker born every day and you
sure found the punch but every time I
heard your voice I nearly lost my lunch
that muzzle mud on your face always made
me sick
you look just like a dog staring up in a
cartridge
and you love to work the crowd like a
villain in the ring
Wars
[Music]
[Applause]
how you ain't wore that thing in years
but when John Stewart burns your ass it
was music to my ears you push their
propaganda son you served your mass as
well
[Music]
I will see your ass in hell
all right a great great song Tennessee
Brando hits every time on these and let
me tell you something Tucker [__] you
and I will see you in hell buddy I will
see you in hell um so this is the um the
uh Walters little uh thing and before we
go Tennessee Brando if you're not
following him on Twitter and Tick Tock I
don't know what you're doing right
you're missing you're missing it you're
missing it whether you like country
music or not get get over there and
follow Tennessee Brando um so this is uh
Walter asking New York New York New
Yorkers about Tucker Carlson's being
fired at Fox News so here's what they
think about it there on the streets
Tucker Carlson's out Tucker Carlson was
fired how's everyone doing now the
Tucker's gone you all right how do you
feel about Tucker getting fired
who's going to explain white supremacy
to our stupid viewers I have a funny
feeling he may have signed a good deal
with Donald Trump yeah exactly how do
you feel now that Tucker's gone
feel devastated I thought he was such an
asset to Fox he was the one who was
willing to stand up and say this
election was stolen and point out the
unfairness of the prosecutions and
everything else in this country the
older will privately he didn't believe
me but publicly he did yeah
no one else is going to be able to
explain white supremacy to our viewers
the same way he'll be missed thank you
thank you what do you think of Fox News
firing Tucker Carlson
uh it's New York man suspect the worst
thank you how do we feel about Tucker
Carlson getting fired
couldn't make a statement with Fox News
and he sucks anyways did you get Tucker
Carlson fired he doesn't work at boxes
no he got fired all of y'all remember to
vote for Donald Trump 2024 you vote for
Donald Trump I put my [__] inside I'll
eat you out [__] what oh god
foreign
listen
um uh Walter's doing the Lord's work
there in New York trying to uh get some
kind of sense to be made out of these
people believing Tucker Carlson what he
says publicly is the truth but in
private he's lying he's obviously lying
in in private when no one's watching but
in public he's telling the truth it's
some weird [__] Texas can you see the
old white guy though man I mean it just
and it just really gobsmacking that that
he I mean just acknowledges out loud
well yeah he doesn't believe it but he
says the part we want him to say out
loud and that's all that matters it
doesn't matter that it's not true it
doesn't matter there's anything but
he'll say it and that's all that matters
that's [__] Insanity man and we've
got a plague of it there it is a disease
it's an absolute [__] disease I have
a few more pieces of business I want to
um to address here Deidre I hope you're
doing well uh Deidre
I think she's in the chat today so I
forgot yesterday to tell you
um I hope you're recovering well from
your surgery uh also let's see foggy
Ozark says Gabe is gabulous
so wherever that I see this comment here
and I yeah couldn't help but laugh Anna
Bay says uh
again Gabe dressed like that says that
was a mind [__] yeah well it's uh
something else that you stayed in that
outfit for the remainder of the show I
mean I can't change yeah
Murdoch okay well maybe we should uh
have Rupert on for an interview uh Texas
Polly also sent me something for a final
piece of business we're gonna check in
on the Anheuser-Busch inbev stock
tanking today oh wait
oh wait it's not taking it's it's still
up uh today so
um and if you go to if you go to six
months on that it's just it's just
obvious it's just well here slowly
climbing like the rest of the academy
wait wait I thought I thought they lost
five billion dollars
a way
[__] and
you know it's like that old guy do you
know what inbev thinks when they lose
five million dollars in Market
valuation in a day they're like okay
tomorrow we'll get eight million of it
back like this look look at this this is
six months look how this stock goes up
and down up and down up and down up and
down up down and as it as it from the
beginning of the six months to the end
of the six months you see that that is
when did but when did that jump go to
the highest point right there and at the
beginning of April March 30th 30th
that's my birthday oh it's my birthday
yeah I was drinking Jaeger but maybe
imbev owns Jaeger I don't know that's
awesome that's why they went up that day
the stock went Sky High because Tony why
you gotta keep doing what you do every
damn day is that old guy that we just
saw on the streets of New York
believes inbev stock has tanked and that
they won in his heart of hearts he
believes that [__] that's funny [__]
that's great that's great I'm glad that
he believes those lies to be quite
honest with you and the reason why is
because the truth the truth can only
hide for so long right a lie is always
naked right out in the open so
um you know if they want to keep
believing the lies that's up to them I
I'm very confident in the American
people the American people are much
smarter that to know that that that
Dylan Mulvaney having a an endorsement
of beer that she didn't even know what
it was literally in the video she's
drinking it and she says I don't even
know if I've ever drink Bud Light before
I I was not a solid endorsement of Bud
Light by bystander I actually frankly I
don't have much Bud Light paid for her
to do that but it would I wouldn't pay
almost any amount of money for her to
unenthusiastically be like yeah sure Bud
Light if you like it go try it they
printed me again cool ah I'm I'm cool
but like but you know what did happen
what did happen with their marketing
campaign is six months ago they're up
they're up 18 points from six months ago
that's 39 38 that's well almost 39 from
six months ago so hey the marketing to
the lgbtq community Kid Rock you dumb
[__] it's working it's [__]
you know what I learned I I did not know
this I I thought it was a limited run it
was one [__] can yeah yeah
with her face on it that's why one plan
that's why none of the cans that they
were destroying a Bud Light are none of
the cases that they're destroying but
like had her face on it had rainbows on
it had anything about the lgbtq
community on it because it does that's
what they that's what they wanted they
were they were active and this again
shows you how dumb they are when it
comes to like the canceled culture and
we got to cancel this product or
whatever this company they actively
sought out that can they bought cases in
cases of Bud Light hoping that they
would get the one with her face on it so
they could shoot it or destroy it or
Chuck it or throw it in the trash or
whatever
but what they found was it was just a
regular Bud Light can it said Bud Light
that was it right and if you want it and
if you wanted the ones that had the
lgbtq writing on it I believe it was
specifically tall boys that it was done
with but all these other [__] were
buying 12 ounce cans so they're all
normal cans
oh they are the dumbest they are the
dumbest and we will make sure to stay on
them and mock them every single day here
on the Tony Michaels podcast Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
don't forget to subscribe I'm sorry
Brendan oh yeah
and heartfelt apology over here from in
Texas Paul Texas Paul sincerely that was
a dick move on my part that he I didn't
know it was it was it was sarcasm and I
am sorry for all the harsh [__] I said
even though you didn't accept my apology
you dick
down face right upside down face so
everyone if you're not mad at Texas Paul
for um him not seeing the sarcasm go to
realtexaspall.com no I'm I'm kidding go
to realtexaspall.com go follow Texas
Paul everywhere uh watch his shorts that
he's been making uh they're great and
and also uh go to what was that show.com
it'll take you directly to Gabe
Sanchez's patreon page he's probably
gonna have some what was that coming why
there's a Tucker Carlson one coming out
good while you're on patreon.com
checking out Gabe Sanchez is Tucker
Carlson what was that go to patreon.com
the Tony Michaels uh we've had a lot of
new members over there we've been having
fun on the Sunday rant I got a new CL I
got two new clips I'm going to show you
this week on patreon so um and you're
gonna get an early look at those uh
today and tomorrow so make sure you go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels join us
over there make sure you download every
single episode of the Tony Michaels
podcast it's free 99 didn't cost you a
single nickel an apple Spotify and
Google make sure you follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels all so if
you linked your Amazon Prime account to
the Twitch account if you did that make
sure you're renewing it every single
month I know it's kind of a pain in the
ass but if you want us to get two or
three dollars of Amazon's money you got
to go in and renew your subscription
once you link the account so go do that
for us that helps us out a lot here on
the Tony Michaels podcast same time same
place tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon